do you think there are more doors or
wheels in the world i know this is a
pretty heavy debate on tick tock right
now but i need to know what you guys
think is it gang gang buzz buzz
it's a thing on top
he said sore doors or chris mystic
because he's texting but he said sore
so he said sore yep gang gang buzz buzz
hell yeah dude i'm gonna say doors
because even on a car that has four
wheels there's also you know
five doors if you count the trunk you
know what i mean so wheels or doors a
trunk is just an extra door that's what
i'm saying so hold on and every car
they're counting the car the doors on
the car that's what i'm saying the doors
doors but if you think about a high rise
think about a high rise all the office
buildings definitely doors definitely
doors
what about theodore
what about larry trunks those don't
count what about donnie so you adore
that's what you're saying
you're theodore right that's your real
name hold on oh my god i call them you
guys are asking if there's more doors or
wheels technically
anytime you want to show up to the
episode
it's a debate on tv no no no no no no no
no
no
no no no no no
it's
wheels it's not
well first of all what you talking about
all doors yes
all doors
all doors matter yeah car doors yes the
car door is counted
earlier
even houses
but what about this they got doors with
wheels on them pull up doors with wheels
on them
if you do anything that's
and how many cars there are there's
first of all there's more how many
buildings are there in the world and how
many cars are there so many
houses think about think about how many
doors on cars and then all the cars have
doors how many door airplanes about the
car doors and how many doors no
airplanes have more than two wheels no
they don't i mean what the [ __ ] who you
flying with mighty mouse
are you one like one of those like you
know dust buster things you know what i
mean like no airplanes have a lot of
wheels they got like those big one in
the front two on the wings one in the
back
rich bro i think y'all might have like
eight wheels yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying hello wheels yeah it's two two no
it's it [ __ ] all right you gotta do
car doors then doors they got six wheels
airplane four doors how many wheels
[ __ ] 19 wheels dude
one two three two three four four four
five six seven eight nine ten but you're
thinking about those are just three do
you forget about the doors the doors to
the bathroom doors to the cockpit thank
you're just being contrary right no i'm
not dude i didn't realize we were i
thought we were talking about like doors
into places not just cardinals what
about those phones where people have
that into a place you're not you're
feeling our door you're not saying if
you add car doors then doors because the
only thing that wheels i have a plenty
of are on cars so the cars also have
four doors because you got like at a
grocery store you got the the the
cartwheel yeah but you need to get doors
into the grocery store and how many
wheels are on the car that's a good
[ __ ] point i don't like this
challenge i don't want to have to think
about this this is why it's a challenge
people need our help yeah do we have an
answer nick we are we are making it
who's counting that though and what
about the phone that have that little
door on it oh that's not a door that's a
flap come on dude yeah what about the
doggy you forgot about the doggy door
two and one thing all right so how
little so a door on the door but what
about the dog that have no his leg got
hit by a car and he got them wheels on
his back yeah couch his wheels
two wheels all the trauma from theo's
childhood what about bike wheels and
what about cassius clay that
motherfucker's in a wheelchair yeah two
wheels think about a wheelchair people
two wheels two wheels cassius clay or
not if you're in a wheelchair think
about the fat [ __ ] at disneyland on
the scooters three wheels
do you have the answer nick did you guys
have a big wheel no no nobody would ever
have the answer dude wait did you guys
have green machines
did you have big wheels
he used to drive by colleges and he
would yell out the window i know the
answer here yeah yeah yeah that's not
and they gave me a degree it's pretty
cool hold on
did you just hear what he said yeah
nick do you know the answer yeah
is that not fair there's no answer bro
they keep making wheels and doors every
day how many [ __ ] wheels and doors do
they make yeah but who the [ __ ] gonna
can we not estimate can you not google
how many tires in the world how many
doors in the wires or doors there are
dude you know how many doors we have a
and how many cars crashed and how many
wheels there are no more had this how
many doors came down this is what's been
going on since my absence what about uh
an advent calendar with all those little
doors on it all right dude you're
getting obsessed about the doors all
right i think it's doors what about
little model cars you know they got the
doors yeah those cats but they also got
doors but then also they have wheels but
their wheels don't turn a lot of times
the doors cancel out the wheels on a car
because it's so basically take cars out
just take cars cars don't matter if they
do matter but they don't matter like
your tire has only two doors okay
yeah but what if it's a sedan
cars
[Laughter]
bad cars you get jim jim morrison he's a
door he's a door one door and there's a
door and there's four door doors dude
four doors but they're [ __ ] four
doors like they don't drive to gigs they
got wheels man what about wheels parisi
that comedian that keeps no they keep
doing fundraisers no no no that's one
wheels
wheels one wheel yeah and he's gonna die
i can't believe we don't have an answer
that's insane the answer is different
now that it was an hour tires on all the
fat people
no
this is falling off the rails
what is it falling off the
[Music]
and the sting and the wing
[Music]
you